programmé ou codées un jeu de dominos le
projet sur lequel travaillent les 23
apprenants de la promotion développeurs
web de l'école simplon avec un esprit
d'entraidé entre les personnes formées
des profils différents avec plus ou
moins d'expérience dans le numérique on
démarre à partir d'une page vide et ont
créé le code en entier ce qui nous donne
un rendu qu'on peut visualiser
directement on fait des tutoriaux pour
sa prendre les uns aux autres ce que
sont les notions de javascript je
voulais compléter mon expérience de
graphistes développeurs web et dans le
domaine de la communication pour être
une professionnelle complète
je pense que les intervenants en ciel
très bien les cours je comprends
parfaitement les apprenants viennent
d'horizons différents le plus jeune a 20
ans et le plus âgé 52 ans porté par
saint quentin en yvelines simple on
accueille aussi 20 apprenants dans une
promotion de développeurs date à une
table une base de données relationnelle
de clients de produits et de
transactions ce qui implique des
factures des transactions et ainsi de
suite
on s'est parlé en fait aux des
différentes bases de données
quand on reçoit des données par exemple
on commence dans une nouvelle boîte ils
ont plein de plein de donner du style
des clients des noms de clients des
adresses etc
il faut tout simplement les mettre dans
un tableur histoire que ce soit plus
clair trier faciles à retrouver
potentiellement rechargeable 35 heures
de formation par semaine du lundi au
vendredi sur sept mois avec à la clé un
diplôme équivalent bac + 2 un formateur
pour chacune des promotions et une
pédagogie proactive pour les apprenants
le but
pour chaque apprenant oda prenantes
c'est de s'autoformer donc ils sont en
groupe il travaille trés principalement
toujours en mode projet ça veut dire que
de trouver la ressource par eux mêmes
dans un premier temps à la fin de la
formation prévue le 31 juillet ils
seront considérés comme des développeurs
juniors une deuxième promotion et déjà
prévu les dates ne sont pas encore
déterminées